Im Sommer 2018 gelang einem Forschungsteam
der NASA etwas Sensationelles.
Den Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern
war es gelungen, Bakterien direkt an Bord
der ISS mit einem Test zu identifizieren.
Aber außer Krankheiten warten noch mehr große
Risiken für die Astronauten im Weltall.
Die drei heftigsten - jetzt bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
Sciencevideos, abonniert den Kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts
und herzlichen Dank für Euren Themenvorschlag
über Discord!
und Herzlich willkommen
Platz 3: Die Schwerelosigkeit
Die Menschen sind nun mal eigentlich nicht
für ein Leben im Weltall geboren - und das
zeigt sich schon an den Folgen der Schwerelosigkeit
für den menschlichen Körper.
Nicht umsonst müssen Astronauten-Teams nach
ihrer Reise ins All erst einmal wieder lernen,
auf der Erde zu laufen.
Kein Wunder, denn obwohl jeden Tag Krafttraining
auf dem Programm steht, geht die Rückenmuskulatur
im All um etwa 20 Prozent zurück - und das
schon nach ein paar Monaten.
Kurios klingt auch erst einmal, dass die Hälfte
der Astronauten auf der ISS an Schmerzen im
Bereich der Wirbelsäule leidet.
Und das, obwohl der Rücken ja entlastet wird.
Und der Rücken ist nicht das einzige, das
durch die Schwerelosigkeit in Mitleidenschaft
gezogen wird.
Denn das Blut im Körper verteilt sich und
die Flüssigkeitsmenge verringert sich.
Viele Astronauten leiden unter einem Blutandrang
im Kopf, denn der Mechanismus, der auf der
Erde dazu führt, dass das Herz gegen die
Schwerkraft arbeitet und das Blut in den Kopf
befördert, gerät durch die Schwerelosigkeit
im All gehörig durcheinander.
Das zeigt sich an angeschwollenen Schleimhäuten,
die sich nach einer fiesen Erkältung anfühlen.
Deutlich wird das aber auch noch einmal nach
der Rückkehr der Astronauten-Teams auf die
Erde: Sie können sich tatsächlich zunächst
nur kurz aufrecht halten.
Denn dann werden Gehirn und Kopf zu wenig
durchblutet und sie werden ohnmächtig.
Platz 2: Kosmische Strahlung
Auf Platz zwei ist die kosmische Strahlung,
die man als Astronaut im Weltall abbekommt.
Denn kein Raumschiff dieser Welt kann diese
gefährliche Strahlung so gut abhalten, wie
es die Atmosphäre, die Ozonschicht und das
Magnetfeld der Erde tun.
Auf der ISS ist das weniger ein Problem, weil
das Erdmagnetfeld einiges davon bereits weiter
Außen abhält.
Mars-Missionen, die demnächst anstehen, würden
aber auch bedeuten, dass die Besatzung eine
große Strahlendosis abbekommt.
Und fest steht: Sie kann das menschliches
Gewebe und Nervenzellen tatsächlich schädigen,
da sie die Aluminiumhülle des Raumschiffes
durchdringen.
Mediziner Teams befürchten, dass die Strahlung
direkt auch Auswirkungen auf die Astronauten
haben könnte: Beispielsweise könnten die
emotionale Stabilität und die Reaktionsfähigkeit
nachlassen.
Aber auch das Krebsrisiko steigt durch die
Strahlung.
Forschungsteams weltweit sind dabei, Medikamente
zu entwickeln, die die Wirkung der kosmischen
Strahlung abfedern könnten.
Beispielsweise, indem die menschlichen Zellen
strahlenresistenter gemacht werden.
Platz 1: Menschliches Versagen
Auch wenn dieser Punkt vielleicht erst einmal
nicht auf der Hand liegt, landet er doch auf
Platz 1: Und zwar rede ich von menschlichem
Versagen.
Das zeigen Statistiken ganz deutlich.
Zwei von fünf amerikanischen Raumfähren
waren abgestürzt und das nur, weil die Verantwortlichen
bei der NASA dachten, dass die bekannten Probleme
nicht so dramatisch seien.
Ein schlimmer Irrtum!
Ein weiteres Beispiel: Apollo 13.
Hier konnte die Besatzung noch gerettet werden,
doch das ist bei Mars-Flügen ja schon fast
ausgeschlossen.
Denn die Erde - als sicherer Hafen - ist viel
zu weit entfernt.
Menschen machen Fehler - und wir sind eben
alle nur Menschen.
Und wenn ihr jetzt an Künstliche Intelligenz
als Lösung für das Problem denkt, muss ich
Euch auch hier enttäuschen.
Denn selbst eine KI kann nicht jede gefährliche
Situation richtig einschätzen und angemessen
reagieren.
Geschweige denn abschätzen, was die Menschen
an Bord in Zukunft für Fehler machen werden.
Umso wichtiger ist eine gute Arbeitsatmosphäre
und ein Team, das zusammen funktioniert.
Das hilft auch dabei, eine Art Lagerkoller
an Bord auszuschließen.
Denn das könnt ihr Euch sicher alle vorstellen:
Im Weltall gibt es keine Privatsphäre.
Noch schlimmer also als im Büro oder Betrieb,
wenn man den ganzen Tag auf seinen Arbeitskollegen
abhängen muss.
Und jeder hat ja so seine Gewohnheiten: Schmatzen
beispielsweise oder aber immer den selben
Witz erzählen.
Und anders als wir es von der Erde kennen,
kann man eben nicht mal schnell nach draußen
gehen und durchatmen.
Und die Reise mit der ISS ist ja nun auch
mal nicht von kurzer Dauer, ganz im Gegensatz
zu einer möglichen Mars-Mission.
Mehrere Monate wäre man dann unterwegs und
die Astronauten hätten auf dem Weg erst einmal
nicht so viel zu tun.
Hier müssten also auf jeden Fall Räume geschaffen
werden, die zumindest ein wenig Privatsphäre
möglich machen.
Denn auch wenn sich Schlägereien in der Schwerelosigkeit
eher schwierig gestalten, würden Streitereien
und Feindseligkeiten einer guten Atmosphäre
im Weg stehen und dann im schlimmsten Fall
auch zu menschlichem Versagen führen!
Die fundamentale Bedeutung der Raumfahrt Draufklicken,
anschauen und natürlich die Neugierzone abonnieren.